joe biden now the official democratic
white house nominee accusing the
president of failing the american people
our current president has failed in his
most basic duty to the nation
he's failed to protect us he's failed to
protect america
and my fellow americans that is
unforgivable
as president i'll make you a promise
i'll protect america
i will defend us from every attack seen
and unseen
always without exception every time
in response president trump coming out
swinging this afternoon the president
saying
democrats held the gloomiest and
angriest convention ever
they spent four straight days attacking
america
as racist and a horrible country
that must be redeemed joe biden grimly
declared a
season of american darkness
and yet look at what we've accomplished
until the plague came in look at what
we've accomplished and now we're doing
it again
i'm thinking kellyanne conway now she is
counselor to the president she is at the
white house kellyanne great to see you
this afternoon thanks for joining us
john i want to give you an opportunity
to
rebut the vice president's speech last
night on policy first of all
let's listen to what he said about
coronavirus and then come back
we'll develop and deploy rapid tests
with results available immediately we'll
make the medical supplies and protective
equipment that our country needs
we'll make sure our schools have the
resources they need
to be open safe and effective
we'll put politics aside we'll have a
national mandate to wear a mask
not as a burden but as a patriotic duty
to protect one another
the the vice president saying kellyanne
in short he will do
what the president should have done from
the beginning your response
it's a confounding display of the
intersection of arrogance and ignorance
because he doesn't know what we've done
on coven 19.
firstly when he says it's your patriotic
duty to wear a mask he sounds like
president trump who said it's your
patriotic duty to wear a mask and
tweeted out a picture of him wearing a
mask and basically said i'm wearing a
mask you wear a mask the same week
he recognized that people can't go to
the bars places of worship places of
work places of learning
and so he pulled down his own live
in-person convention and stopped doing
these big rallies as well
because the president believes what's
good for thee is good for me
vice president biden also said things
that you would think somebody other than
one who had been in washington for 47
years and vice president for eight
uh would never be able to say with a
straight face and it's this
he's saying we need to develop ppp in
the united states great idea but it's
president trump who says buy american
hire american make in america they left
us a depleted national stockpile
we didn't have enough ventilators we
went and using the domestic production
act and also
incentivizing private americans private
companies john
got all this ventilator capacity so that
every state that requested ventilators
got ventilators the governor in new york
said we need
42 000 ventilators or some crazy number
we gave him four
we gave him about four percent or 14
percent of what he asked for and he
started giving other ventilators away
thank you
so much is not true right but i think
the record on that has been well
articulated but what
biden said which is different than the
president is a national mass
mandate he also said that he would not
muzzle his experts
and i think it's fair to point out that
we have not seen dr burke's dr redfield
dr hahn or dr fouchy
i know just had polyp surgery in public
we have not seen them
at the coronavirus briefing for some
weeks now well if you haven't seen dr
fauci in public you don't own a tv
or a computer you've got to be kidding
me he's a member of the task force who's
out there almost daily
uh giving interviews to many diverse
outlets
and none of us has ever said please
don't do that my seat in the coronavirus
task force briefing i'm just a staffer
is right behind
doctors berks and fauci so we certainly
see them they're
reporting directly to the vice president
that the president has every day
so and you mean that you mean the press
hasn't been able to ask them rude
questions like
the one that was asked by a colleague of
yours from a different network of dr
fauci
are you here on your own volition
i mean what is he patty hearst with the
uh i mean what is this in other words i
i read well hold on but this is
important saying that
joe biden say won't muzzle the experts
when our experts are on the coronavius
task force and unlike a lot of people
like joe biden we were working around
the clock here since march on the
chronovirus task force you know in less
time than it takes to have a baby
we have developed six different vaccines
and three at least three of them are in
the final phases of clinical trials in
people
all of this is still a six-month effort
that we've been that we've been doing
and we've got therapeutics vaccines
money the strategic national stockpile
so
a lot of what joe biden said was false
and by the way if you have the
if you have the uh audacity to say the
president didn't protect americans and
you don't mention the violence in
democratically controlled
cities you're just lying to the public
okay let me move on to another issue
social security and taxes this is what
the vice president said last night
and for our seniors social security
is a sacred obligation a sacred
promise made they paid for
the current president is threatening to
break that promise
he's proposing to eliminate a tax that
pays for almost
half the social security
any way of making up for that lost
revenue
resulting in cuts i will not
let that happen now kellyanne the
president has on at least a couple of
occasions said if he is reelected he
will end the social security payroll tax
but it is my understanding that that is
not the plan
that he's only planning to cut it until
the end of the year and then forgive
that tax
what is it as far as you know the latter
is more in line of what he's trying to
do
by the way he only did this two short
weeks ago because
joe biden's democratic congress
including his vice president kamala
harris won't come to work
and pass another phase four so that the
president wouldn't be forced to take
executive action on his own he announced
a suspension of the payroll tax that's
it that's a temporary thing
because he wants to make sure that we
keep this economy humming
in the same executive actions john he
gave 400
extra unemployment benefits to some
america to many americans and also said
that you're free from evictions and you
don't need to pay your student loan debt
for the rest of this year those are big
measures
to help americans with their monthly
bills donald trump said as a candidate
the same thing he's done as president
which is quote he will not touch social
security and medicare
that's made a lot of you know right
wingers very upset
and he has said i'm not touching these
i'm preserving them and this is a
president i was on an interview with him
earlier today that he
he gave to a senior a big biggest
seniors group in the country where
he went through the entire record
medicare premiums are down
the lowest in seven years he's lowered
the cost of insulin to 35 dollars
maximum a month for our seniors
uh he's developed a kidney care delivery
in a very different way which helps a
lot of them who suffer from renal issues
and he has and and when it comes to
seniors the telemedicine telehealth
measures
that have happened on this president's
watch in the last couple of months have
been nothing short of transformative
we want to make them permanent we had
about 13 000 telehealth
visits by seniors before the pandemic
were over 10 million now so
seniors can still access quality timely
care from their doctors
but through the privacy and security of
their homes without risking covet
exposure the list goes on and on happy
to provide it to you
the dnc is over now we're looking ahead
to the rnc next week
david plouffe who is president obama's
campaign manager said that the president
has got to reach out beyond his base
let's listen to what he said he's
basically continuing to dig
his own political grave and so the
question is is he able to change next
week
are those voters going to hear something
new something more hopeful
something more disciplined or are we
going to hear about hunter biden and the
elections fraudulent
and barack obama as a criminal like his
base will love that they'll cheer and
the rest of the american people are
going to tune him out
so kellyanne what is the president's
message at the rnc going to be about
will it be about the the future and what
he will do in a second term
or will it be about joe biden and the
democrats it's a combination of the
progress report of his first term and
then the vision piece for a second term
and it took joe biden less than two
minutes last night to listen to donald
trump i was a little surprised with that
because all week long we heard
we want to unify a broken country we
want to talk about what we're for or not
what we're against
but they can't they don't know how to
beat him but they certainly don't know
how to quit him
him being donald trump the most popular
two words said at the democratic
convention all week were not joe biden
they were donald trump
but in this in this case the president
will he's got something to say about
what he's done here
in the 47 months much more than joe
biden's done in the 47 years
but pluff has a point that people here
including the president hear from me
often
which is is just this you know the
exception of 1972 when
incumbent president nixon had decisive
advantages in that election
from 1960 to 2016 our electorate has
always gone for the presidential
candidate they saw it
they saw as more forward looking
optimistic and pleasant they certainly
did in 2016 but they did other times too
when democrats and republicans won
people want to hear
optimism they heard a lot of negativity
a lot of them invected this week i think
jill
jill biden jill had the most positive
upbeat speech but
she was really singular in that regard
the president just today
said joe biden's speech the convention
was way too angry and gloomy
and he believes in the hopefulness and
the greatness of america i think you
heard that
uh out at his july 4th speech and at
mount rushmore i think you've heard that
in his poem he heard that many times so
he will appeal to the best the other
thing is not just the message of next
week it's the messengers
we're going to show the rpi the real
people impact of
the trump pence administration but for
them being here john and these policies
happening people won't have the jobs
they have the small businesses wouldn't
be
thriving and surviving uh individuals
who are addicted to drugs or who are
languishing in jail
they would not have a freer path towards
their futures and you're going to hear
directly from them
just just before we go one quick
question the president on hannity last
night said
that it was his intention to have
sheriff's law enforcement and
prosecutors
at polling places i assume that these
would be people who are off duty because
there doesn't appear to be any provision
to have
on duty members of law enforcement there
and what do you say to democratic
charges
that that would be voter intimidation at
the polls who are they intimidating as
opposed to who
uh the folks who give me the side eye
when i tell them they're looking in the
wrong registration rules for my name
is so it's not voter intimidation i
thought the democrats agreed with us
that one vote one person the sanctity of
your vote is your constitutional right
and also your civic duty
do they not want us to safeguard these
elections they can't even figure out
what they're doing they thought they had
the new postmaster general lewis dejoy
on the ropes today instead he just said
i haven't discussed this with the
president
and by the way people have been
complaining for decades about the
inefficiencies of the post office you
finally have a president who's willing
to fund them but also try to reform them
and everybody's up in arms i thought the
most important thing today in the postal
conversation
is a tweet that the u.s postal service
put out just a little bit while ago john
where they said
um that they expect between september
election day
two percent of all the mail will be
ballots two percent so they know that
they can handle that
well that is a good t up to our next
section because we will be talking with
congresswoman debbie dingle about all of
that
kellyanne conway good to see you thank
you so much thank you john
we'll see you at the rnc next week